qui va repartir avec ce téléphone 5 g
c'est grâce à notre ami mfh on a ce
téléphone c'est le dernier iphone douche
pardon excusez moi attention je vous
posais des questions sur la téléphonie
à chaque fois vous donner une bonne
réponse il y aura deux chiffres qui vont
s'afficher et à la fin il y aura un
numéro le premier qui m'appelle sur ce
numéro gagnant le téléphone vous jouez
gars bien sûr chez vous je sais qui rend
fou tout le monde
cet iphone plus attention c'est parti -
cascades dit wii u pu plus ou moins de
10 % des françaises conservent bien au
chaud les échanges de sms avec leurs
anciens compagnons pour les faire
chanter au cas où c'est plus ou c'est
moi c'est plus plus de 10% way qui le
fait qu'ils conservaient ces mets
typiques vous oui mais j'ai a do une
application secrète où on peut aller au
maire de la femme en garde j'avais une
application certaines j'entrepose
effectivement les jeux des balles
sévèrement les textos ça fait partie des
souvenirs il y en a des photos ou des
messages et les messages sont jolies on
n'a pas envie d effacer même si on est
passé à autre chose on a envie de garder
delphine bossi et moi quand c'est des
beaux messages je les imprime m j'ai
même déjà imprimé par action de poires
les gars que vous avez regardé des
messages de personnes ici de d'amidon de
benjamin de guillaume je voulais moi
aussi j'aime et j'ai tous les rats j'ai
tous mes messages
il ya des messages anti mais ya beaucoup
de messages anti d'aller des dossiers et
bien c'est une bonne réponse de madame
rice a dit va pour cent des avancées sur
servent bien au dessous les échanges de
sms vous vous conservez les télégrammes
c'est vrai qu'il n'avait pas le
téléphone portable de mon engagement
ça c'est l'info du jour
question pour vous delphine en moyenne
un jeune français de 15 ans pas de plus
ou moins de quatre heures par jour sur
son téléphone plus c'est sur les plus
sûres et même ceux de 20 ans et même ses
deux camps près 27 40
ils passent moins à abonder qu'à une
étude qui est sorti ils passent en
moyenne trois heures et quarante minutes
joua loin on n'a pas de chiffres
attention les chéris si à la fin du tour
j'ai pas le bon numéro personne ne gagne
le téléphone est si c'est comme ça
jean michel mr oui plus ou moins de 20 %
des français ont déjà envoyé un texto
par erreur à un membre de leur famille
mois -2 20%
est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé à quelqu'un
ici bah oui bah oui pas régulièrement va
régulièrement ça arrive à tout le monde
même pas les textos forcément c'est pas
des forcément des sextos mais les choses
un peu gênante je vous en envoyer un
jour par erreur mais comptent pas etc
rachid arhab a
j'avais écrit rachid arhab et je vais
fait une copie d'écran et g au lieu
d'envoyer à bouger envoyé rachid arhab
et marié gens visiblement c'est
confidentiel notre conversation
c'est avec mes copines je fais la
réflexion sur la qualité de trois mois
je vais vous raconter un jour il ya et
ashley raconte téléspectateurs comme je
les tire à côté messieurs vous donnez
nous un jour quand je n'étais pas au on
était pas hyper copain laurent ruquier
mois on n'était pas fâché mais à un
moment il ya eu des petites tensions et
j'avais demandé à jérémy jérémy ont
frappé chez un ami qui travaille avec
lui à la capote
je vais demander est ce que tu peux me
donner numéro de laurent ruquier et
jérémy michalak m'envoie à moi yahaya
hanouna qui votons numéro 1 mondial lui
donne
je vous jure que c'était magique
vous avez réagi recevez ce n'est ce pas
vous l'avez revue n'ont donc plus ou
moins bon sens des français ont déjà un
sursaut paraît vraiment de quoi
guillaume ça vous est déjà arrivé
ouais à ma mère voyez sur what's app est
la palud ouais je me suis trompé j'ai
supprimé at on peut supprimer les
messages mais d'abord pourquoi les
petites le pas en parler s'il ya les
ignore mais 19 cdsoft pourquoi c'était
dans ce contexte se tait quoi genre et
georges or j'ai envie de toi on n'y a
pas un meurtre un peu gênant pas choix
et je sais que c'était pour rené à la
base alors vous savez quand on peut
arrêter un message l'envoi d'avions
moins d'avions vallori absolument savoie
le connaisseur très rapide enfin les
chérit plus ou moins de 20 % des
français ont déjà envoyé un texto par
erreur un membre de leur famille vous
avez dix mois - très bonne réponse de
jean michel mercier
attention à la numéro 6 07 61 je
rappelle que le premier qui m'appelle
repart avec le téléphone iphone 12
george szabo ça j'adore j'adore grâce à
guillaume oui genton oui à 10 heures
près à combien s'élève le record de la
plus longue conversation téléphonique la
plus longue conversation téléphonique à
10 heures près
130 heures non 130 heures non non non
non non c'est 50 6h04 c'est en afrique
du sud
voila voila je vous le dis cinquante six
heures voilà c'est la plus longue
conversation téléphonique voyez qu'on
apprend des choses à 19h54 pour
l'instant attention on a atterri blain
pour l'un sert aux 7 61 je vous dis si
je fais le tour de table et que j'ai pas
l'ensemble du numéro c'est à dire qu'il
ya encore deux mauvaises réponses à ces
morts le téléphone il repart il repart
très bon à la pression plus on voit de
32% des français ont déjà répondu à un
appel alors qu'ils étaient en train de
faire l'amour plus ou mois qui l'a déjà
fait et delphine ben oui non et tout le
temps mais moi j'ai pas tout le temps
même quand vous faites l'amour avec
continue mais quand ça sonne j'ai
toujours l'impression que c'est
important et je décroche mais plan
répond du peuple et pas répondu claude
tour nous ne vous ai pas dit non mais
c'est vrai bah oui parce que du coup le
téléphone est juste à côté donc voilà ou
alors je mens modèle est généralement je
suis en mode avion toute la journée sauf
quand je passe les côtiers le bon
sillage avec roger
oui oui le prends pas mal il adore ça
décrocher quand on fait l'amour c'est ça
ouais bah moi j'ai déjà fait c'est une
question à ce point femme quand on
m'appelle je décroche
[Rires]
décrocher vous en pis aller pour qui
c'est à dire j'ai 1940 et numéros
enregistrés
d'accord mais pas en réussite et je
réponds pas d'accord c'est bien donné ce
soir
alors ya beaucoup de coups de fil il ya
beaucoup d'amour mais 32% c'est déjà
beaucoup j'ai envie de dire - moi qui
décroche pourtant et c'est plus car il
va nous faire perdre le téléphone de 41
en séquençage
voilà c'est bon allez merci on n'est pas
et on n'est pas aux soins cela dit
d'accord car en terre pour son père elle
répondent quand ils font l'amour
ah oui bien sûr vous je sais que vous
n'avez jamais j'attendais un appel
important pour un autre a et pour sauter
sur la forme donc je me suis noyée alors
je réponds jamais un joli qui reste avec
craintes en coupe quand tu entends tu
décroches au téléphone disent qu'ils
décrochent quelle encre sur l'année elle
l'appelle où ça fait 20 ans que je n'ai
pas fait l'amour
y'avait pas levé quand je ne fais que
décrocher certains gens voyagent au
carreau alors daniel le record du lancer
de téléphones portables à mains nues et
il a plus ou moins de 80 m c'est mal et
moins
vous êtes nuls joël dupuch ses plus bas
oui c'est plus ses 94 m attention il ne
faut plus qu'une erreur une erreur
attention rené malleville a réussi à
rené malleville sur son français 22 % se
disent stressés lorsque leurs compagnes
touche à leur téléphone portable
vrai c'est faux vrai ou faux parce que
c'est plus ce que ces mois ci même à
mettre tous
elle touche au téléphone c'est le touche
ton téléphone
tracy m'accompagne toujours téléphone
qu'à moi j'appelle oui
[Rires]
c'est par rené donc tu as un téléphone
portable
oui donc si ton téléphone portable en
main est ce que ça te stresse un peu et
bien n'a jamais fait donc je peux pas
être autre autre question mais oui à 78
sur wii est ce que vous stressez vous
quand votre compagne prend votre
téléphone raymond banon site à site a
rien dedans les rayons je stresse
géraldine non pas du tout maxime est
rien à cacher d'accord alors qu'il
chante on sait pas qui stresse mon frère
c'est pas ils épargneraient que je ne
donne pas mon téléphone de la personne
non non surtout pas attendez si vous
voyez des choses compromettantes
mais que sa vielle genre bah je sais pas
mais y'a mais alors je regarde les
priorités et il m'envoie tous et c'est m
ils m'envoient même si photo il
s'embrouille et dernièrement avec un
animateur
ah oui je raconte tout et il m'a envoyé
les captures d'écran de son embrouille
avec l'animateur nos retraites ça mais
c'est vrai j'en doute et je suis je te
suis venu en aide
c'est vrai tout de suite voilà moi aussi
je vous soutiens quoi va oui bah bien ce
jour toujours série s'embrouiller avec
un animateur dernièrement par sms chaîne
tf1 et vous êtes embrouillé avec lui
vous aussi je dis bâti bonne nuit mon
numéro de m'appeler et vous a pas
appelés non japon qui guide ultime
diagonale comme ça c'est le mec comme ça
il est chez lui il est pas bien et
commence à 10h chéri [ __ ] appelle les
secours j'ai l'impression que j'ai fait
un avc bien j'ai mal au coeur et c'est
sa famille libyen va te donne moi ton
téléphone j'ai plus de batterie mais qui
ont fait ça va mieux
[Rires]
aller aux jeunes 07 61 72 attention 07
61 72
deux questions pour géraldine maillet je
ne veux plus une erreur sur son france
[Musique]
attention contient en plus c'est pas du
tout ça qui que c'est déjà pris que
c'est déjà pris un français sur cinq
à force de regarder son téléphone dans
la rue à poteau où un piéton un piéton
non un poteau d'accord il faut une
réponse un poteau un français sur cinq
s'est déjà pris un poteau le regard de
son téléphone et oui attention
il nous reste encore un succès non les
mains de patrice des questions 34% des
hommes ont déjà téléphoné aux toilettes
et un appel déjà il ya d'ailleurs qui
régala ça compte pas
l'aca compte paraissent pour l'instant
ça compte pas alors ces 34 pour son nez
oui j'en sais aurait utilisé leur
téléphone aux toilettes allez moi je
sais plus bon c'est que c'est plus oui
oui c'est vrai ou faux la piste c'est
fois d'après fo qui l'a déjà fait ici
ouais bah ouais non mais même les femmes
même les femmes aussi vous le fasse et
le meilleur endroit pour téléphoner à sa
meilleure copine
oui bien sûr sur sa meilleure copine qui
s'appellerait jean-marc merci c'est ça
va donner
comprenez un petit peu ce qui sera
non mais attends quand il disait alors
il analyse les marseillais on les
comprend pas qu a dit parle alors à
somain j'articule qui devrait faire un
peu comme les marci juste une question
que je suis idir vous aimez daniel
moreau j'adore enfin il cherchait audrey
grondin cremo la bouffe et qui sera de
retour vendredi à l'aider chéri cynthia
alors cynthia qui est sexe et s'occupe
des chroniqueurs et on est si bien sûr
en amitié des hommes ont déjà téléphone
aux toilettes
c'est fou wii plus et c'est moi c'est
vrai 21%
oui mais alors attention le téléphone
laisser apparaître le numéro après sa
part est le numéro 1 c'est parti
attention ali je réponds 7
allô allô allô oui bonjour quand vous
appelez bonjour series et julien julien
attabi tout mon julien à thionville à
thionville je connais très bien
à thionville le pont tampon
merci julien tu fais quoi dans la vie eh
ben mon chéri tu gagnes
voilà c'est fait mais voilà il part ça
l'est par contre c'est magnifique
j'adore ce jour j'adore ce jeu pourra le
refaire
on rit on pourra le refaire joe zawinul
inquiète parce que tu voudras géraldine
d'amour